What has Massachusetts given us?
A liberal governor who wanted us to believe he is strong on defense.
A liberal senator who wanted us to believe he was a man of the people.
And a Massachusetts moderate who runs away from Ronald Reagan.
Look, I was an Independent during the time of Reagan-Bush.
I'm not trying to return to Reagan-Bush.
Romney donated to Democrats...
...and given the choice to vote in the Democrat or Republican primary,...
...Romney chose the Democrats,...
...voting for a liberal Democrat instead of President George H. W. Bush.
Romney opposed the contract with America, raised taxes...
...and authored government mandated health care with taxpayer-funded abortions.
But now he tells us, "Trust me, I'm a conservative".
Massachusetts moderate Mitt Romney: he'll say anything to win.
Anything.
And just like John Kerry, he speaks French too.
But he's still a Massachusetts moderate.
And a Massachusetts moderate cannot beat Barack Obama.